a little musical interlude here let's
see
here maybe i'll play the uh glock and
spiel to let people
know exactly what we're doing here uh
their sound effects should be coming on
we're talking with
i know
beautiful intro music written by one of
my good friends
miguel tully aka yeti tears
who provides a lot i'll play with black
and spiel there's a glockenspiel
i don't know exactly what a glockenspiel
should sound like but
hey you know you could tell me if that's
actually correct
wait for people to find here yeah it's a
glock mosquitoes when you have builds
you know lots of bells lots of bells
tinkling bells away
excellent all right we got a bunch of
people coming in
we're gonna have a great time today
talking with
one of the uh the leaders working on the
cutting edge
the cutting edge of uh of shadows of
space-time itself
and that is uh that is heino falca
who is joining us today from the lower
regions
the netherlands uh where he is a
professor
at radford radboud radboat university at
nightmare about yeah radboud okay so
some things that
these are hard um and we're gonna talk
about the event horizon telescope
because uh i know i think that is
uh it is unequivocal that you were one
of the first
originators of these terms that we
search for the shadows of black holes
the event horizon that we're looking for
that we have found
you your team has found in 2019 when you
made this wonderful press conference
release
uh which later resulted in um and many
uh well-deserved accolades and uh
and and awards all over the all over the
world you
are currently as i say a german
professor of astroparticle physics and
radio astronomy
you won the 2011 spinoza prize as well
as a 2006 academy prize of the berlin
brandenburg academy of sciences and
humanities
erc grant uh was uh
originated by you uh for uh some of this
organizational
um you know the founding of this project
and other projects to test
einstein's theory of relativity and for
a long time
i have to commend you because i thought
you guys would study sagittarius a
star i thought that was going to be your
first target but instead you turned to
messier 87 and i want to talk about why
that choice was made and what the
announcement that was made just
yesterday
implies for astronomy for cosmology for
physics
but first of all can you tell us a
little bit about the event horizon
telescope and what its mission is to do
yeah i mean today this is a um
a big collaboration of uh 350 scientists
around the world it was founded by
13 stakeholder institutions among
among them was you know my university
but you know other places like harvard
mit uh max planck and bonn
institutions in asia
and we
try to image black holes we try to see
them
and that was my long-term dream actually
to finally see a black hole
it started all for me 25 years ago when
i was
indeed looking at the black hole in the
center of our milky way
and i realized that
um you know there's light coming
directly from the event horizon radio
light at a particular frequency and that
was what our models were
were telling me and then
you know people in bonn were working at
this technology very long baseline
interferometry which you know turns the
entire earth
into a telescope and um
[Music]
and then at some point i you know i i
found some old books about
you know relativity which described how
black hole you know
would bend light and and if in fact you
know it amplifies itself
and um and so what that means
is that the dark region the event
horizon would become actually larger
than i had actually thought before
and it would be shined you know our
models would tell us he would shine
light at it
from all directions and
you know with that magnifique
self-magnification of black holes
this you know what we then later called
in this publication in 2000 the shadow
of a black hole
would possibly be observable
by a worldwide global telescope
operating at the highest radio frequency
something that was just in the infancy
at the time but that was such a
tantalizing realization
that um you know we we could be
see looking into the darkness of
black holes and actually resolve that
scale
see you know see almost down to the
event horizon
where you know all light disappears
where information disappears
um and and from then on we started you
know working on it i started working on
it doing
more theory some observations um
and then we published this paper in 2000
and then
colleagues in the u.s started to do more
experiments a group of dolmen
developing broadband digital equipment
and in
in the 2010s 11 12 we you know we
thought we'd
all have to work together to make this
happen
uh there's only one world and it doesn't
belong to just
one institution you have to work
together and
if you want it or not you know um you
you have
you you if you want to see black holes
you need the entire world
and and out of that came the event
horizon telescope which
is uh you know was was a
was a rocky start at the beginning and
and now is
is really you know gets going and
and and and and and
and pushing through uh the data and
and the science where the stakes are
very high
and you have to be very careful uh what
we do
and so that sometimes it takes a long
time so it's still
not that you pick a call and you publish
it
no it takes not much longer
um yeah i want to talk as much about the
team and how we
uh how we come to understand the uh
the nature of large collaborations i
think is very mystifying to most
scientists uh non-scientists rather and
even to some scientists
you know we're used to thinking of uh
scientists the lay people
might look at a scientist and say oh
they're very specialized
you know i don't have any right to to
learn about what they're doing because
you know i wouldn't go into a doctor's
office and and just start you know
messing around with the x-ray machine or
something like that
and that's a specialized piece of
equipment and this is a specialized
piece of equip
but um but i think these types of things
that you study
are really uh captivating of the whole
world as was shown many uh you know just
a few years ago
and yet i think the public thinks about
scientists is all just one big family
working
happily together but i see it sometimes
you have to
combine almost rival teams as as you
mentioned
in order to use the resources that are
necessary these telescopes
in your array if i'm not mistaken
include telescopes at the south pole
in chile uh europe everywhere across the
planet so it took a planet-sized
telescope to do
the work that you did talk about what is
harder measuring the the event horizon
capturing the light shadow or assembling
a team
of hundreds of scientists around the
world to get them all working together
on a common goal i i think the latter
certainly for most of scientists we are
used to
sit behind the computer do our stuff sit
behind the equipment make it work
work overtime make sure you know we we
we get the results we have and overcome
obstacles
but then they're always you know
annoying uh other people right you have
to work with they always have different
opinions
um and and usually you write your own
papers and then you know
you disagree and you go to conferences
and then you discuss things but you do
your own thing
now here you have to agree on what to do
how to do it
and um and how to publish it and you
have to check each other but you know
what is
a a challenge sometimes a a sociological
challenge to
to uh egos and individualists as a
scientist is also a strings in the end
because we only have one world we can do
this experiment
only once um
we we need to make sure
we we check ourselves
so usually you know if you're on your
own you publish a paper someone else
comes out that's all crap i have a
better idea
and then they stand next to each other
and takes a long time until you you know
the community accepts
what is correct and who did you did
proper
data reduction who did proper analysis
who had the right models and
and and so what
here you know as i said we need the
entire world
uh we only have one group publishing
this
so that competition that checks and
balances we have to build
into the collaboration it cannot be a
monolithic one thing which is just you
know
one you know ruled by one person
and then uh you know that's what we do
we have multiple groups
and and and it became sort of a mantra
that almost everything we do we do at
least
twice or three times and and now i
learned a new word quintupley
contra five times um
so in the latest paper where we
published this polarization you know
which tells of magnetic fields around
the event horizon
uh there were five independent teams and
methods that all
agreed with each other and and and you
talked to the coordinators
and uh that's a stressful
process but i think it's a if you then
look back at the outcome
yeah and and you see what has all been
done because people are pushing each
other
they are you know they say you know i've
done it this way you know we
we need to do this check we cannot be
entirely sure we have to rerun this
uh the final outcome
is is really impressive uh i think what
you know what you achieve together
um in what i call um
competitive collaboration um
is is so much better than what any
individual can achieve
yeah it still needs the vision and ideas
of individuals and also the egos
um but it uh it is you know this is
nothing you can do on your own
uh we have a question from a good friend
of the show ernesto eduardo
dubard guenez i think is how i pronounce
uh ernesto's last name he's asking
uh would a gravitational wave distort
the geometry of the event horizon
or not even would it even affect
anything
inside or outside the event horizon can
gravitational waves
uh from the black hole first of all do
they does this black hole emit
gravitational waves and then can they uh
perturb either inside or outside of the
event horizon
yeah that's a great question
luckily at this point gravitational
waves do not play
an important role for these black holes
because they're isolated they're on
their own they're
they're sleepy so to speak you know
they're they're not bothered by
by anyone else um rotational waves are
created if you have two black holes
merge
or if you have something really you know
sizeable object fall
into uh the the supermassive black hole
then you disturb space-time
and you radiate gravitational waves and
it actually does affect
they affect each other uh they affect
each orbit and they affect their um
even their metric uh the space time
around them
so um we have a very
stable environment the metric is the
same today tomorrow and in the future in
the next hundred thousand years
the the space-time curvature of m87 will
not change at all
and that's as big strength compared to
the gravitational wave measurements that
that you know
um because there you have you know two
black holes merge and it goes very quick
and that's
bang and you hadn't seen them before you
see the gravitational waves and then you
have to inform the problem infer all the
parameters and then they're gone you
can't
you know verify this anymore uh you can
you know you have lots of information
from from the data
uh we at least can go back and and we
have fewer sources we have much fewer
sources but these few sources we can
check over and over again in fact over
the next hundred years people can verify
what we have done
on this source it will still be around
you can measure its mass better and
better
so that's a big advantage so you have
fewer but you can do them much better
um and and then you're testing really
different aspects of gravity
to some degree you know in one case
you're testing the dynamics and we're
testing the
space-time geometry space-time curvature
right that's what we're measuring
another good friend of the show reminder
talking to hino falca
of rad uh bowed university uh in
the netherlands talking about the event
horizons uh
really monumental discovery announcement
yesterday we'll get to why that's so
important
in just a bit just a reminder please
subscribe to this channel hit the
subscribe button
and you'll be notified we have a lot of
live streams coming up we have david
spurgle coming up very soon
and we're going to have john mather
winner of the 2006 nobel prize
don't want to miss these conversations
and uh leave a comment and uh thumbs up
and follow uh haina on twitter his
handle is hfalca
over there on twitter so a question from
sebastian clark
can a black hole diffract
gravitational waves can act as a
gravitational lens
or even absorb the energy from a
gravitational wave
that's a good question i'm not the main
expert really on general relativity but
i think that
that is the case um because you have
gravitational waves
uh you know they deform space time and
if you if you run through gravitational
you know
the only the only object that really in
a major way
change space time is is um
our our black holes i mean earth as well
but you know it's it's a minor change
and gravitational waves to some degree
behave like light
um and and light is is is being
deflected
uh around uh black holes and
uh in fact if you calculate
gravitational waves that are being
emitted
from this this merging process you
you're really making you know
[Music]
the same kind of calculations to some
degree as you would do for light you
know rotation waves or
um even if even emitted at the same
radius
um you know if you see that ring of
light
that we see in m87 this comes from light
going around the circle
more or less uh around the black hole
you know light is almost 100 percent
bend
and the emission of gravitational waves
happens at exactly the same scale this
is where the regression waves are
you know produced you know and and
released
so we are really probing the same kind
of physics
and the same kind of scale spatial scale
as in in in with light and with
gravitational waves
and really probing even the same aspect
of the metric you know there's there you
know there's
this space metric is a spacer matrix is
described by various components there's
a timeline
metric and that's directly related to
the size of that ring and to the
emission region of gravitational waves
so really there are lots of similarities
even though they're completely different
techniques to some degree it just the
difference is one is dynamic and the
other one is is static
very good and one is lightning is
spacetime spacetime light
is that a word that we can invent so
let's talk about
the telescope itself uh can you give an
overview it's a worldwide telescope it
has it's a radio telescope
which means it operates uh primarily at
uh at millimeter free wavelengths and bl
and above but can you say more about
what are the
primary components of it and uh and
was this detection yesterday this
announcement yesterday was this always
in the planning or
were you guys kind of surprised by it or
serendipitously found the
magnetic fields were were um were robust
enough to detect and actually do
scientific
uh make scientific measurements with
yeah yeah we're using rated helps it's
actu
radio telescopes it's actually a network
so the telescope is a network of of
telescopes so it's a
telescope of telescopes um a very
hierarchical
uh structure so to speak um
and uh you know we have as you i think
you mentioned that before we used to
have eight
telescopes on six different locations
among that this really giant alma
telescope it's a billion dollar
billion euro
[Music]
telescope which in itself consists of
smaller telescopes
yeah so you have alma which has i think
64
dishes which are combined into one
telescope and then that telescope is
combined with all the other
seven telescopes into a worldwide
telescope so really
you're building up that uh that
that structure from from from fewer
telescopes to more to
even more telescopes um
and and you have a telescope in the
south pole a 10 meter telescope it's a
small telescope
but you know the south pole is a very
dry and cold region
and millimeter waves that we observe are
actually affected by
the humidity in the air so you want to
go to a high mountain where it's really
dry and south pole is actually
perfectly suited for this
i myself was in you know initially in
arizona
there's a telescope which you know used
to be a german
american telescope now it sort of
belongs to arizona on its own
and then it was in spain there's a 30
meter telescope
in the pico villeta it's just near
granada uh
you know sort of you can almost see the
alhambra and you can see the the oceans
from the mountains and you can
go skiing next next door it's a it's a
wonderful telescope's a massive
big telescope um which
usually looks for molecular lines which
looks for dust or for chemicals in
in the universe and only when you
combine it with all the other telescopes
it gets the resolution
to uh to see the
um to see the event horizon yeah so all
these telescopes have their own
personality i always say you know
is and that has you know gives problems
also telescope is only human
uh after all right so it's run by humans
it has its own uh quirks and
and and problems and and and properties
uh that need to be taken care of um and
then you have to make sure it all works
it works all in in synchronization
and you put atomic clocks next to the
telescopes to synchronize them that's
still not good enough
because you need to then correct the
atomic clocks by looking at
actually um quasars and black holes in
the universe which actually act as
reference points and therefore you can
use them also as
as to correct your your clocks
uh um you need to actually in
when you bring the data together later
you need to take into account uh
aspects like uh well the precise
position you need to be to to a fraction
of a millimeter you
need to sort of determine the position
of the telescopes across the globe
um in the initial models people you know
measure and take into account
continental drift
uh the tidal waves i mean the earth
breezes you know it goes up and down
uh all these these things have been put
into these models actually over the last
decades you know we didn't invent this
we make use of
like 40 years or 50 years of of work on
vobi
that has come to a culmination really in
in this experiment so i could go on and
on and you know talk about the polar
wonder right
the earth wobbles uh and that's
something you would see
uh in in in this video bi data uh like
you know some of these you you you you
can calculate sort of jupiter pulling on
on the earth so you know the earth
wobbles a little bit
but then there's a 10 meter or 20 meter
wobble that's left and that has to do
with the
the ocean swapping around and the the
air being on one side a bit more than on
the others or whatever
so i mean the the earth is pretty round
but you know it
at a certain level everything becomes an
egg
and and that's right um
so good so we have another question are
there observations ongoing i know a lot
was cancelled due to covid what's the
current status of observations
yeah good good question i mean we had we
were extremely lucky 2017 we had uh
uh our annus mirabilis mirabilis uh you
know a
miracle year where everything worked the
weather was fine all around the world
all the telescopes worked
and and we got all the data we needed um
and uh by the way i didn't answer the
previous question i have to come back to
you know whether that was polarization
was planned or not
and in 2018 we tried again and then you
know
some telescopes were weren't ready some
receivers were not working
um we uh
we had bad weather in fact i was in
spain you know i couldn't see the top of
the telescope it was so foggy we were a
little in the middle of clouds
uh and that was maybe we couldn't see
even the brightest radio sources we
couldn't see anymore
in in in in some days um
and then at one telescope even you know
one of the crew was actually
uh held at gunpoint um and we stopped
the observations because it
it looked it was too dangerous in in
that region
and it was an entire telescope was shut
down actually for a year or two
uh because of of security issues
and then 2020 2019 we were all
extremely worn out and some telescopes
weren't ready again
for maintenance and other reasons and
security issues as i mentioned
and then we're hoping 2020 yeah we're
going to observe again
well you know corona struck like really
i mean
the last telescope you know we dropped
it two weeks before
the observing run then you know it was
clear there was a global lockdown we
couldn't do the observations anymore
but 2021 looks like it's gonna happen
in april so maybe we are lucky
and we have more telescopes now we have
greenland telescope
we have in france and nuema array
uh by iran it's it's on the french alps
a two and a half thousand meter
altitude plateau uh
in in in in the snow it's a wonderful
dish it's very harsh conditions but you
know
i've gone up there by helicopter i got a
vip treatment
once by them and and you fly up there
and you think it's like james bond movie
because you know you're going up the
alps nothing is there and then suddenly
out of this you know on this top of the
mountain you see
you know these 11 by now should be 12
silver dishes
15 meter in diameter with a big building
in the center where
actually entire dish can be moved into
it um
and and so it's bizarre but you know
it's taking data for
for i don't know 20 or 30 years now i
don't know how old it is now it's uh
probably in the late 80s it was built
um yeah these are wonderful dishes in in
um and each one of them has it has their
own stories
and and people and yeah usually
wonderful places
and each of them has different food
right so if you're in spain you get an
illusion food
if you go to france you get french food
and if you go to arizona you get deep
fried pizza
that you get from the practice well you
get nopales yeah
uh and in greenland you what do you get
you get danish food
i haven't been there i might say yeah
it's interesting because that's
a it's it's it's officially danish
territory i think
uh but the greenland people are you know
feel pretty independent i think
uh and the telescope is run by
our colleagues from uh taipei
so oh wow oh so it's really truly
international even within
it's very funny arizonans running in
greenland and taipei
um so we were going to talk about
polarization and the announcement that
was made yesterday and we'll take more
questions reminder i'm talking hi no
falca
who's one of the leaders and originators
of the idea of looking for light
shadows isn't that interesting i always
say what i do is interesting because i'm
looking for
the exposure of gravitational waves on
the cosmic microwave background
radiation so we're using
waves of light to expose waves of
gravity in sort of an old-fashioned film
camera metaphor
but you're actually looking for shadows
of gravity
that are deleting out light sort of
acting as a as a
as a sink as a vacuum cleaner for light
and that was one of your
main uh or you know kind of inspiring
ideas
way back when before we even got funding
to do this project so
uh talk about what is polarization i i
my
audience as you can already tell is
extremely astute they know a great deal
but there are some non-experts out there
what is polarization of a radio wave and
why does that tell us anything of
interest
about black holes that we didn't know
before
yeah well polarization is something that
we
usually you know
or directly um you may actually notice
if you go to if you have a polarized
sunglasses
or actually 3d movie they typically have
polarized glasses which
you know switch on and off in in some
coordinated fashion
um and there's a hidden property of
light that it has a direction
of uh of oscillation it's a light wave
and it oscillates in a certain plane
it can oscillate you know from left to
right but it can also oscillate
up and down and normal light from the
sun
is unpolarized it oscillates you know
the half of the light is going left
right the other half is going up and
down
and so that averages out but if you
shine light on for example glass
you know it's reflected off glass then
actually light gets a preferred
direction
uh it it will be polarized only a
certain you know
orientation of uh of this
oscillation will be emitted and the same
happens
if you actually produce radio emission
uh a very
simple example if you have an an an
antenna just a little rod antenna right
you have electrons going up and down and
they produce electromagnetic waves
and the waves will be sort of polarized
you know which is sort of determined by
the
direction of of this antenna
so you'd have to want to get unpolarized
radio emission to transmit you'd have to
have an antenna go up
and one antenna go left to right you
know i have a cross essentially then you
would get unpolarized radio emission but
if you have one antenna
it's only one polarization that you pick
up or that you
transmit uh and and
and you know detectors can you know our
eyes cannot see that
i think some animals can actually see
polarization yeah
bees and but
but we have to use you know radar
telescopes polarization filters to
actually translate that for us
and uh and so radio telescopes can do
this
they can split the radio waves up into
different polarizations in fact they
always do
and so this was always in our data and
was always planned
it was actually something we always had
to take into account
um so the only problem really only
problem quote unquote is just to
uh to calibrate it properly to make sure
the outcome is right and that you know
from
we had the data since 2018 on our
hard drives um but you know to actually
reduce and calibrate it
took uh three years right uh and you
know
understand everything it's just you know
because you need to understand every
little detail into the force
um so that that is a hard part
and what does it tell us about black
holes well
um you um
[Music]
auto radio light will be polarized near
black holes
and what is polarizing it its magnetic
fields
and magnetic fields play a very
important role
in controlling the gas flow that's
falling into a black hole
they can actually uh you know they can
be dragged along and just disappear
in the black hole or they can become so
strong that they even
halt the the the plasma
they form sort of a star trek like
shield
right around the black hole which could
even
protect gas from falling in and they can
be wound up
and lead to plasma shooting out uh
on along the rotation axis of of the
black hole
and so black hole magnetic fields you
know
on earth you know we use them to for the
compass and to measure
you know direction of uh where columbus
would go right so we usually don't use
we don't see them as very strong
effects but around black holes these
magnetic fields really
determine the dynamics and the entire
drama
playing around black holes and they
polarize the light in a certain
direction
typically in a direction perpendicular
to the magnetic fields
and so the image that we published shows
the polarization of light
you know the the direction where it you
know uh oscillates
and sort of the magnetic fields that
where it comes from is roughly 90
degrees
relative to those fine lines that you
see in this
in this image but then there are also
relativistic effects and so forth so
the real image in the end is much more
complicated how black holes look like
nothing is simple around black hole
nothing is simple but
more or less you know if you see that
polarization you know polarized light
you
you roughly get a feeling where the
black where the the
the magnetic fields are and what they're
doing so yeah one of the um
the properties of black holes they're
kind of like particles
they can have a lot of different
characteristics uh
but actually they're you know they're
limited to a handful we have
mass charge and spin and black holes uh
can have similar properties but almost
no more right isn't that the so-called
uh
no hair theorem of black hole uh that
they're they're really
kind of fungible in a sense they're
they're they're
that complex in in a in a deep sense in
that sense black holes
black holes are the most boring uh the
most
boring objects in space right so they
have these two parameters the spin and
the mass and that that that tells you
everything about it
right um so
but they uh
they they look and they they don't have
hair as you say right so they're
the black holes themselves do not have
the magnetic fields right
so you cannot thread magnetic fields
through the event horizon for example
yeah they go from the inside to the
from the inventories and to the outside
like we have on earth right we have a
magnetic field that's generated inside
you know in the poles you have this
colloidal magnetic fields and goes to
the outer space and protects us
as well and you know and connects to the
inside that's not possible in black
holes
so if if magnet fields fall into it the
mag's fields will be
cut off and cut off from the rest of
of the environment yet we see those
magnetic fields
very close to the event horizon that's
anchored in the uh
in the plasma that's rotating around
it's being amplified
so while black holes cannot have hair
they can have a wick you know i i
i like to say and so they're really you
know surrounded by this you know hair of
magnetic fields
but it doesn't go inside and that's i
think an important thing to understand
what can we learn more i've had on lenny
suskin and sir roger penrose and others
and
um in roger penrose's case he talks
about the
singularity is sort of the most
interesting aspect of a black hole
uh lenny suskin on the other hand will
say no it's the
what he calls the stretched horizon uh
he it's sort of above the event horizon
by
a plank length or something like that
what is the most
interesting aspect of a black hole and
what
kind to you personally and then what
kind of future
properties of light we've this we've
seen that the light has a spectrum
we know it has polarization we know it
has isotropy or patterns
um thereof are there any other
properties that have yet to be
discovered um uh we've seen time
variability you've made
what would be the next not the next
major discovery although i hope that
you'll
clue me in next time there's a big
discovery i'll keep it confidential i
promise
uh but uh but are there other properties
of light or radio waves that can be
exploited
uh not speaking specifically but can
other discoveries be made
using the capabilities of technology
that was a good try to getting some
confidential information out
but um now let me start with the last
question before i go back to the i think
more fundamental question you raised at
the beginning
yeah uh what actually is what makes
black also interesting
certainly one of the the important and
maybe long-term
goals really is to see whether black
holes are spinning
and that can produce a very interesting
effect in combination with magnetic
fields
in fact the the the black the spin-off
black holes will make the space around
black holes also co-rotate
and you know magnetic fields are in that
space and they'll be drawn along
and this way you can actually transport
energy
transport rotationally energy
from the black hole to the environment
you can actually you know slow down the
rotation of a black hole through
magnetic fields that are threading
around it and put it into a powerful
plasma outflow
and we we are you know
we think that's what's happening really
what in m87
uh at least in our simulations when we
try to explain what we're seeing
uh the effect that gives at least some
fraction some significant fraction of
the energy
to this outflow is actually spin energy
from the black hole
that's not not the entire story but that
that certainly is an important effect
and and this is a very fundamental
mental effect that you know was also
i think also by roger penrose was the
first one to describe a process with
light where you can shine light on a
black hole it can actually extract
spin energy from a black hole by
scattering
light in a different way left or right
around the spinning black hole
so that that's a very fundamental thing
you know really
you know isn't that cool right you
extract energy from a black hole i mean
this is
mighty you know all right yeah jan 11.
it might be better and you just tap into
it and you get
uh a huge amount of energy out and
that's what the supermassive black holes
do
um and in the in the very long run yes
of course
it's it's it's this big question what's
really happening at the event horizon
what's happening with information what's
happening with liberty
and in and um indeed it's it remains a
fundamental question you know maybe
the the event horizon is totally boring
you know at least in relativity when you
fall through the event horizon you know
nothing really
exciting happens um you know it's just
you wouldn't even notice really uh
anything happening to you
and even like a super massive black hole
like m87 you could fall through it you
would be
you wouldn't even be ripped into pieces
because it's you know it's so big
tidal forces are not so strong you know
you were so small compared to
uh that big big black hole but you know
what's happening is the singularity and
the annoying and almost
um yeah these this yeah this
mightily annoying aspect is that we
we we can't know right so because
because it's inventorized we can't look
into it there's some
extremely exciting physics where time is
reversed where
all the matter has to turn into
something that we have no clue of what
it is
right how can you have six billion solar
masses in it disappearing and something
that is
almost infinitely small what's happening
there
um some extremely weird physics that's
beyond our
our understanding and we can't measure
it
that's so it's like i always compare
this to uh
like like christmas time right so you
have you know
at least you know in the old days my
parents would you know
you would all the presence would be in
the room and then the door would be shut
right i would not be allowed to go in
and you could peek through the
the keyhole a little bit and try to
figure out what what's going on there's
this christmas tree and all this
presence around and so forth
um but you know you know next day
tomorrow
you know or we celebrate in the evening
you can go in and you know and look
what's in there
right and right now it looked like you
know the universe and god tells us right
so
yeah there's this wonderful physics
inside but you know this thor i keep
shot right you know just you know
go off you can look so with you all but
you know you're going to see anything
and that that makes it so um so dramatic
for physics
you know rattling on this door we try to
get in we try to understand what's
happening inside black holes
we can dream about it we can uh we can
have many theories
there are so many ideas and theories uh
you know from penrose to this currents
but many others
um but how are we going to test it and
this i think is is sort of a
you know the big battle that we are
going to fight in the next uh
i don't know years 10 years decades 100
years
thousand years i have no clue whether
and when we will solve that
right no that makes it so interesting um
yeah but i want to go as far as possible
that's why i wanted to go to this this
edge of black holes
maybe you'll go journey someday into the
black hole with uh
with elon musk and spacex so we're
talking today again
i'm happy to let him go i you know i'm
i'm i'm i'm ready to you know i'm i'm
willing to stay behind
and that's right enjoy this this planet
like someone's gotta host the press
conference at home uh
so we're talking again with i know falca
it's one of the leaders of the event
horizon telescope you can find them on
twitter h
falca and uh you can find our vent
horizon telescope i'm showing some
images
here on youtube please do subscribe to
this pod
podcast wherever you're listening to it
or watching it just hit the
hit the subscription little bell there
or whatever it is or wherever you may be
getting this and on clubhouse we are
going to take questions in a few minutes
as well we've been taking some
on uh youtube and facebook we're on
facebook youtube and twitter periscope
as we speak so we got all the technology
here we're using it all hannah
make it good i want to also point out
that that the heinous book is coming out
in the u.s at least in may i think it's
already out
some parts of the universe right yeah
it's
a it was already out in german i you
know it was easier for me to write it in
german
uh then it got to the netherlands and
then in spain it's out now and now it's
coming to the us at
may the 4th may the force be with you
it's a widely chosen
date star wars day and then you can you
know read the entire story of the event
horizon telescope
from um in fact the first first view of
a little child you know was inspired by
the moon landing
to the first view together with with
students and colleagues
of of this entirely new world uh
the uh the exciting region around black
holes
yeah it's an amazing journey from you
know the really the
you know the first astronomers looking
at the stars to to us now looking into
black holes we've come a long way really
yeah we certainly have and uh even in
just the last couple of weeks it's been
the news won't stop yesterday or two
days ago i had on james beacham
uh and phil elton of the large hadron
collider and the atlas experiment
and the lhcb beauty experiment
that detected potential evidence for a
fifth force of nature
new materials new matter new violations
of fundamental symmetries
this announcement came the day after uh
by your team
and uh your collaborators uh you know
who knows what's gonna come next
a couple weeks ago similarly there's
been just a spectacular news coming out
of all
quadrants of astronomy and physics and
it's just an amazing time
we landed a helicopter on mars and we're
going to have an airfield on another
planet
which actually has a piece of the right
flyer you know this little fabric uh
segment of the original flyer one that
the wright brothers
flew from kitty hawk and now it's on
mars and they set up an airport there
so there's going to be tsa delays i'm
sure
but stay tuned for more great uh events
on this channel we have david spurgle
coming up john mather
uh and many other great guests coming up
as as well as professor sarah seeger who
made a big announcement herself last
year of uh potential
evidence for phosphine which is a
byproduct we think of life
she's a guest that will be on very soon
as well so i know uh
in the few minutes we have left we do
have more questions and i want to
uh bring those up so um why were black
how can black holes
survive potentially uh these
these collisions and explosions and and
sort of uh
events that would ordinarily tear
ordinary matter apart what what actually
is the force that makes black holes so
resilient
against the most cataclysmic forces in
nature
yeah and and it is gravity and that
that's really amazing
aspect that gravity is really the
weakest of all forces
uh and and it keeps us on the planet but
it doesn't destroy us
but if we really you know if everything
pulls together in one direction
then gravity wins over all forces in
nature
and that's because there is no
anti-gravity right so in
electrons and protons or you know in
charges you have
positive and negative charges in
magnetic fields or north and south pole
gravity only have gravity and and that
that makes it very special it all
and if you think about gravity is
actually that made our world
right you had this big bang uh but then
it was due to gravity that everything
came together and assembled
and uh and and you formed an earth and
uh
and planets and sun and stars and it's
uh so yeah it's gravity that that
that gives us life
[Laughter]
in in in this universe and yeah when it
all you know
when it it runs away when gravity
becomes stronger than anything else it
claps it forms a black hole and then
there really is nothing there to
to to um to escape it's its grip
and that is uh very yeah it's very
fundamental and strange
uh property of gravity and
uh and indeed the last thing that will
survive probably in this universe are
really super massive black holes
yeah i mean the m87 will live as i mean
if even if there's hawking radiation
m87 will live a staggering 1097
years so it's one with 97 zeroes
wow you know i you know in this book i
tried to calculate you know i thought i
tried to explain this somehow
in a way that we can comprehend uh it
was impossible it was like
you know if you know of the lifetime of
the universe
you take one proton one atom out of this
universe
okay every age of the universe
yeah yeah and you keep doing this the
universe will be gone faster than this
black hole will have disappeared
yeah it's just one atom gazillions of
of protons and atoms in this entire
universe that's right you know people
want to
talk about you know a supernova that's
brighter than the whole galaxy that it
lives within but
uh but these black holes have have a
permanence that uh
hollywood celebrities can only dream
about ernesto is asking again that as
entropy not and you said that there's
only these two properties of black holes
but he's asking isn't entropy a a
property related to temperature of the
black hole that's an
another distinguishing feature
well this is sort of a something that
came out of you know
sort of the aspects of quantum gravity
and and you can
but in the end these these properties of
black holes you know entropy
or or temperature are directly related
to the mass
yeah so it's just a different world word
for the mass of a black hole right ollie
is asking
apologies if this came up i don't think
it did but why do you think
that uh there is a supermassive black
hole
at the center of almost all galaxies
what is what is the
reason behind that is it coincidence is
it do they form are they the reason that
galaxies form what is our best knowledge
about that
yeah stuff got to go somewhere right so
and and if you look at the evolution of
a cluster of stars
uh you know you have this distribution
of stars some of them will turn into
black holes they will sink towards the
center
they you know the heaviest objects
typically sink towards the center
and then there's no way to go at some
point they have to collect coal s into
one bigger black hole and then more and
more will come and it will keep growing
and since a black hole
doesn't really evaporate fast enough
enough on any any galactic time scales
it will just get bigger and so it's
almost unavoidable that you have
supermassive black holes at the very
center unless they're kicked out
but you know who's who's ready to you
know to bully a supermassive black hole
out of a galaxy i mean this is
it you know it only can be another black
hole more or less
thor is not going to make it all the way
out there um
uh so and then the next question is more
of a host
prerogative question as the host of the
into the impossible podcast please do
subscribe
and leave a comment if you're enjoying
this and if you're new to the channel
yeah leave a
leave me give me a thumbs up uh in the
in the little
icons there um so what's next for our
galaxy we saw last year
andre ghez and reinhard gensel won nobel
prizes for
the work that they did to image the um
the motion and the dynamics of stars
near the
uh it just said compact object at the
center of our
didn't say supermassive black hole
yeah what is the uh prospects for event
horizon is there
is there something that precludes the
event horizon telescope from seeing it
is it easier to see m87 because it's
sort of uh more massive what what are
the pros and cons of sagi star versus
m87 for example yeah
we should be able to see it right
eventually i'm absolutely convinced
that's what got me going in initially
that's what we wanted to see an m87 was
sort of a lucky shot
to some degree right so and it turned
out to be a very good lucky shot because
it's
it's a big one it's it's uh and so all
the gas that rotates around
takes actually you know days to weeks
like three weeks to go around
so if you take a a picture within a day
it's actually relatively stable
uh in the galactic center stuff goes
around in in 20 minutes or so
so within a day it has it has made many
many rotations
and so that makes it really hard to uh
to image
but on the other hand uh then you're
integrating over a longer time scale so
that actually is better
so we are you know we we are we are more
um sensitive to the space time which is
stable
over uh and much less affected by the
variability of the plasma which you know
can move the shadow a little bit around
and
makes intensity brighter left or right
sometimes
so in the long run such a star the
center of a galaxy will be the prime
target the one that is really most
important and
we have yet to see the event horizon and
the shadow in this
one but thanks to the work of of genso
and gays we know exactly how heavy it is
no it's less than a percent it's a
fraction of a percent we know the mass
we know the mass of this black hole
better than our own mass right
our own weight um and
and so by and we know exactly how big
the shadow should be because that's
related to the mass
um and with this something we we should
test we will test we will
we will see eventually uh we may need a
few more uh
uh telescopes in the long run to do it a
little bit better we may want to go into
space
uh eventually but yes we will see it we
will see the shadow i'm i'm pretty
convinced
and of course i it would be
nice if it would be not exactly as we
expect it to be
but uh you know we have to
we have to wait and see look what the
data tells us and i assume i'll be the
second to know this
next time that's only fair you know
after
after all i've been through uh i want to
ask you about future prospects uh if you
had your choice would you rather have a
another baseline say on another planet
maybe mars is nice this time of year
would you rather have um you know higher
frequency
would you like to do optical i mean
could you use an optical interferometry
and a planetary scale to get even better
measurements of the event horizon maybe
even closer and
zoom in or is this basically at the
limits of what we'll ever know
about the you know kind of the shape
configuration magnetic field of black
holes
we're astronomers you know we want it
all right so yeah
we we want all of this all of the above
um
but yes i mean we first start with more
bass lines on earth to give slightly
more robust
measurements uh we're really at the
limit of uh what we can do
at the moment with this few telescopes
as i said you know we're i'm
involved in a project we're trying to
get the teles
go into a continent is missing
at this moment and then eventually go to
space
and you want to go to higher frequencies
as well you know the higher the
frequency
the longer the separation of the
telescope the better the image
now going to mars is probably you know
initially a bit far away
um to to do it because you really you
know it's overkill you're
really uh having too much resolution
actually
you don't want to do that and if you
want to see
things that are so small that you have
to put a telescope on mars it has to be
insanely big
because you know they'll be weak
typically and
and so um and it takes a long time
for mars to rotate around uh
the sun and earth so you because that's
what we
we're using the earth to look at it from
different directions right the earth
rotates and we
we're using that effect so you know
somewhere in space between you know
a medium earth orbit to uh
you know people talk about even the moon
i think that that probably is already a
bit too far away
um but uh but really yeah we
we've done a study you know what we call
the event horizon imager if you put
three dishes don't even have to be very
big around earth at 15 000 kilometer
altitude from the center
uh you get almost perfect perfect images
uh sharp images you know nothing you
know not this donut anymore you see
wisps of the black hole and so forth so
it's it's
sci-fi can become reality it's a
question of will
and and of money of course so nico's
asking do you have any hopes for the
nobel prize in 2021 i am not going to
talk about that
i assume they know me not you no i'm
just kidding uh yeah yeah yeah
all right wouldn't be out of the
question look how many uh nobel prizes
have gone to black holes in just the
last three years it's
incredible um so i mean i think what
really qualifies me
for the nobel prize i've appeared on
your show i guess so that's uh
that might disqualify you heine you
so last question i have uh from uh for
myself and then i'll open it up on
clubhouse on
a couple more on youtube is um if are we
at the same
you know precipice as you know for
example ligo once once
ligo really made convincing discoveries
now it's turned into you know it has
hundreds of discoveries it has
it's become statistically significant
not just
one-off mesmerizing discovery so i
analogized their discovery
in 2015 2016 with your 2019 discovery
when will you get into the kind of just
you know discovery a day or
imaging a day or will that never happen
based on you know how
exquisitely precise these images have to
be and how much time that takes will you
ever get to the level of statistical
measurements black hole event horizons
every day
yeah good point that that means that's
what i said before the gravitational
wave they have many many sources
but they're gone very quickly we only
have at this point two sources
all the other ones are too far away or
too small all the earth is too small
right so however you like it on the
other hand it's amazing
that the earth is just big enough right
so it's just
right and you you know normally you
could go to higher frequencies and you
become more precise
but if you go to the uh like terahertz
regime higher frequency radios the
atmosphere actually shuts off
so we're really really at the edge of
what you can do from the ground
um but we can do it well we can do it
better
uh and and and i think we have
we want to do a movie we can do a movie
from from from the ground
yeah but it will remain hard work it's
not that we get just bang bang bang many
images each of these
images will be i think a masterpiece and
valuable in itself but it will
increa involve a lot of hard work and if
you want to see you know
dozens and thousands of black holes you
have to go to
to the space mission and that that will
take a while so
um i think every result every paper that
we publish will remain precious for the
next couple of years
yeah every every source every paper just
like every person
uh is precious on the team no doubt i
know it's been such a pleasure i've
started to read your book
you were kind enough to send me an
advanced copy in in english i requested
the german copy
uh i don't know what you did no i'm just
kidding
okay i only know one word in german is
it true that the word
what is the word for ambulance in german
krankenwag krankenvagen yes that's my
favorite word
in all of german call a crank of wagon
for the for keating
i want to thank you for your time and
congratulate you and your team
on success as we said at the very
beginning uh the team and
dynamics and human enterprise that is
science we
are always thought of scientists as
walking wikipedias or something but
but actually the hardest part is to
realize we're all human beings and to
coordinate this
is really a testimony to you and your
team and i wish you great luck with it
and i want to have you back
later this spring once your book is out
and available in america at least
and well i'm already really tearing
through it enjoying it i know we're
kindred spirits
i'd like to talk to you uh in great
depth but for now it's late there you
have plans
for celebration dinner i don't want to
keep you from that and we're going to
sign off so please yes
everybody do look into heinous book you
can get on amazon already there's a link
in the youtube description
while you're on youtube subscribe to the
channel we have as i said david spurgle
coming up very soon you'll be surprised
how soon he comes out
uh sarah seeger and john mather just to
name a few
and you can find past videos to roger
penrose frank wilczyk
as well as with uh as with jenna levin
and katie freeze and all these great
black hole aficionados
do not miss it i know thank you so much
have a wonderful day thank you for going
into the impossible part one
part two to come have a great rest of
your day okay
bye bye bye bye everybody very small
gathering tonight right because of
corona it's just too much
well we have over 250 people watching
currently
so it's we had it we we have a very
large gathering to
uh wish you congratulations